I'll give you just a little idea the
idea when it's very said little Ashley's
not little spirit
[Music]
hi everyone in this video seafood panel
will be sharing some of his thoughts on
the first bomb in Wing Chun seen him Tao
which literally translates the little
idea I'll leave all seafood panels
details in the description below along
with links to his other videos if you
enjoy this video give it a thumbs up
also let me know your thoughts in the
comments and when our next visit
Thailand what would you like to see
filmed now sometimes you see wings guys
do this and this and this and why is
this rotation when you can grab so now
you bring it down now it's antique
rattling single now in the form you see
double now let's say you pin mini crab
and you push it down and you pin them
right now you pin me what I'm gonna do I
can't talk okay
see now hmm I'll take roughly that's it
down up you can do so many things on
that application I mean is you can apply
from that defining Center - high and low
from just that first part you can do so
many thing
come on I'll show you a bit okay one two
love South are cracking punch one time
da straight away come on here here right
now more about comes forward and
punching me like that do you think that
scholars can stop this can stop no the
idea is about fast like place when the
hands come you out now
five C slowly
one two three now you don't stay here
now this is just demonstration on the
reality of the advancing me going move
forward moving outward and go footwork
footwork footwork the second pass no
dice dick could we call it chicken
who is this dick okay so now what you do
it's on one to already in the next he
coming back and if now you can you can
do this way you can hit in the center
first because it's shorter but some of
the some of the the idea is higher now I
show that this is the two different
things one white center because this is
shorter I talked about Sonny's if I hit
there
that's is short if now I'm not moving
okay I'm not leaving forward now see
what happened if I aim in there it's
become a shot now if I aim in there
first
I get him and now everything is well you
stay in here but this is really fighting
come in and hit right now
tiny is apologized timing coordination
you have to practice hard I just give
you the idea second part aiming here be
good in there so part cream again you
know the stance okay now what we gonna
do is understand a people is inside
person in town okay little now part
three Hansel you can see handsaw bhai
so hello now I show you little pansy
here
little tongues penetrate okay so
everything's going forward and slowly
softly forward when you're practicing
practicing slowly get a sequence
sequence right first and then you can
speed up now there's a three different
way first
relaxation see now second checking
now
number two penalty
No
now when you're practicing as then
confused is so many different
semental is because in structure your
seafood master breaks down and he put a
little ID inside and this is little idea
is it breaks down already that's why you
put it together so is his concept it's
not about his master is about himself
personality it's because he
understanding that and that's why you
want to say this is for what for for
situation you might be need to do the
chop you might be jerk you might be
chopped down like that so that's why you
have to learn all of this thing you have
to go through learn to Newtown chunk you
beauty everything then you start it
charge if you don't break down
everything believe me you like it you
like you go like in in kindergarten you
have to start from the beginning start
from the kindergarten go to the what is
after clinical is one primary school
Yeah right you have to learn a step by
step but if you don't if you don't know
nothing is it okay that should be like
this that should be like that
I'm agree with you because it's your
perspective but if you breaks down it
can be everything okay that's now number
three
I'll show you blacks Asian first done
and now folks oh and if you see now I
can't focus on why it's like this why is
like that so many angles of the folks on
tell you think when you have enough
experience it can be anything
now if I want to use power use this
thing if I want to stick I use this
hanging and okay so now I want to do so
that's why hanging here
and this motion opening hey naturally if
it's inside can do straight away like
Xena and the next now if it's about
momentum
you cannot stop that if you stay and you
do like this in them in the form you can
keep one percent it's because you're not
moving in a form it doesn't tell me
anything
that's why learn step by step to doing
this now you will you have to learn step
by step and after that your master and
your instructor you have to explain
goddess you should not staying here and
doing this movie just going forward
penetrant
that is the idea advancing going forward
and hit at the same time okay this is
the way it should be
this is inside force now shows the
outside punching moving again going
forward okay
don't stay and waiting come on boom no
way you couldn't hit you won a percent
so you have to move out step to the side
and go with the whole body
blast this hand position opening it and
go done if you can break your structure
fall out with the chain punching so come
no angle one two three done that's it
you see that is only the time now we go
to
that is the jerky before you doing that
you can do so many way okay if you break
down again if you break down you can do
so many wait time punished time punch
punch want it
and Cena won chill out and you turn but
in reality you don't want to let him
turn around and punch you what you
should do
huh go done in No and so again for
you next
Oh moving move move you stay and you do
focus on the whole hand yes it's funny
take it oh now one tip in or you can do
straight away when you punch now what do
you see
quick quick OOP and punch
that now if you want to go through right
let's say you don't get him you don't
get it him that and you go when you
punish me with the next okay haha back
okay
does he know there's so many thing
inside the phone and that's funny that's
why I can't explain everything okay so
you have to come to class that's it I
talked about small town or when people
talk about savolta this new town is just
give you a little idea what for using
for everything you know you can go in
search in YouTube
there's many explanation but what we
want presenting is give you a little
flavor of our wing charts okay
this Luther ideal might be you might be
missing something so and that might be
can I help you
so I hope like it and please subscribe
[Music]
you